[موسيقى]
اهلا وسهلا بكم في حلقه جديده من برنامجكم
الندوه صالونها اليوم عن شخصيه مثيره
للجدل لا اظن ان عربيا او مسلما او جلهم
يجهل هذه الشخصيه الشيخ محمد متولي
الشعراوي رحمه الله ماليء الدنيا وشاغل
الناس حيا وميتا رغم انه غادر عالمنا هذا
قبل من عام 98 رحمه الله عليه يعني قبل
مده كثيره ومع ذلك لا زال اسمه يثير الجدل
بين مناصر له وبين ناقد له وبين قارئ له
خاصه بعدما ثار الجدل مؤخرا في مصر حينما
اجمعت وزاره الثقافه المصريه على
عمل مسرحيه تتناول حياته سبق ان تم تناول
شخصيته في الدراما المصريه في مسلسل
بعنوان امام الدعاه هذا الموضوع اثار
الجدل مجددا حول شخصيه الشيخ الشعراوي هل
هو الشيخ تنوير
وتعزيز لافكار التسامح وقي التسامح ام شخص
له او شيخ له مواقف مثيره للجدل بل البعض
صفه بانها مواقف متطرفه وفتاوى منغلقه بين
هذا الراي وذاك نستضيف هنا
ونتشرف باستضافه الاستاذ والناقد الفني
والثقافي الاستاذ طارق الشناوي من مصر
حياك الله
نبدا بالموضوع مباشره استاذ طارق لماذا
الجدل لا زال مستمرا حول شخصيه الشيخ
الشعراوي مؤكد ان الشيخ الشعراوي متغلغل
في الثقافه العربيه كلها وليست فقط
المصريه ولكن في مصر تحديدا هتجد انه
عربات الميكروباص كتير منها والتكاتك حتى
صوره اكثر مما توضع صور فتى حمامه او ام
كلثوم او عبد الحليم فده او عبد الناصر
مثلا او السادات فده يدلك على الى اي مدى
هو متغلغل في الوجدان والثقافه الشعبيه
المصريه وايضا قطعا نعم البعض يقول ما
ادري صححني ولا لابسه طارق انه يمكن هو
اول شيخ اواعظ ديني يتحول الى نجم تلفزيون
يعني في ظاهره سبقت ظاهره ما عرفناهم في
العقود الاخيره الدعاه الجدد امر خالد
والتيارات هذه هو هو الرائد يعني يعتبر هل
هذا التوصيف صحيح هو اول فعلا
واعز يحظى بشعبيه تغير كان في قبله
الباقوري والباقولي تعرف من ايام جمال عبد
الناصر من ايام الثوره كان موجود مع رجال
الثوره مع وزيرا اصبح وزيرا للاوقاف في 52
يعني معهد الثوره على طول المهم وكان ايضا
شخصيه لها يعني حولها حب ولكن ولكن العمل
النجاح الطاغي قوي ده كان شيخ الشعراوي
يعني في شيوخ كثيره حوله كان على الجانب
الاخر كان فيه الشيخ كشك بس الشيخ كشك كان
كفيف
نجوميته عن فريق الكاسيت يعني واكب الشيخ
كشك شريط الكاسيت فاصبح ظاهره صوتيه وكان
دمه خفيف برضو كويس بس الشيخ الشعراوي من
خلال التلفزيون المصري الكلام ده قبل
الفضائيات انت عارف قبل الفضائيات كان لو
عملت برنامج كل الدنيا اتفرج عليك لا انت
بتتكلم على 3000 فضائيه يعني عامل الندره
هناك هو اللي يعطي الوهج اكثر مزبوط وكان
برنامج احمد فراج ده مذيع مصري معروف اتهم
من الشخصيه دي احمد البعض يقول انه هو
اللي قدم الشعراوي الى المشهد التلفزيوني
يعني عرف الجماهير بالشعراوي مزبوط ويعني
هو كان بيستفيد من شيوخ وكان برنامج نور
على نور ده برنامج كل مصر في التلفزيون
الارضي بعد صلاه الجمعه تقعد تتفرج على
احمد رجب مذيع ناجح قطعا وكان طبعا حقق
شهره طاغيه بالذات بعد زواجه من صباح
الفنانه صباح رغم انه شخص محافظ هو كان
وغنيت له الحلو ليه زعلان قوي وكل حاجه
يعني
ويمثل معها هو كان شخصيه محافظه ولكن قدرت
تاخده ناحيتها بس
التلاته يحبونا كان واحد من الثلاثه كويس
ولا غنيت له غنوه يعني بينزل لها غنوه
جريئه وواحده بتتغزل في رجل حلو ليه ثقلان
قوي دايما الراجل بيتغزل في امراه لكن هو
كان وسيم طبعا وكان مطلعها بعد كده وحتى
حد احد الجمهور بعث له رساله ونزلت في
الجرائد قال له طلاقك من صباح نور على نور
على اسم البرنامج
هو هو الذي عرف الجمهور بالشعراء لانه
برنامج ناجح ولكن كل اسبوع بيستضيف حد
فالمهم لما وكان بيغير الدعاه لكن اللي خد
الثبات بناء على ايه انه بدا يحس ان في
مردود جماهيري لان البرنامج كان توكشه
يعني كان بيبقى كمان في ناس موجودين في
الاستوديو يسالوا اسئله فلقوا ان شيخ
الشعراوي كاريزماتيك ودي طبعا بتاعه ربنا
ما حد يعني ايه ينكرها على الرجل
عنده كاريزما ودمه خفيف وعنده حضور وطبعا
مثقف دينيا ولغويا
شهره عريضه طيب لماذا الجدل
صفه ناقد فني تعلق بالشيخ الشعراوي
وعلاقته بالفن والفنانين يعني طبعا الشيخ
الشعراوي انا اعرف انه عده معارك وسيره
حول يعني قبل ان ندخل الموضوع الفن مثلا
المفكر الراحل المصري فؤاد زكريا كتب
مقاله شهيره في عام 84 1984 فجريده القبس
الكويتيه تعرفوا اقام فؤاد زكريا في
الكويت وعامله استاذا يعني ومصمم او او
مدبرا ومديرا لشؤون ثقافيه في الكويت وهو
فيلسوف ومفكر كبير نقد الشعراوي في حينه
في عز نجوميه الشعراوي في مقال اسماك كبوه
الشيخ بس نقول كمان انه مواكب لده ما كتبه
توفيق الحكيم لما كان بيكتب في الاهرام
رساله مع الله
فهو قال له لا لا الى الله مش مع الله
يعني يعني يعني بدات الشعراوي كمان كان
داخل في معارك مع توفيق الحكيم اساسا طبعا
مع دكتور يوسف ادريس مع الدكتور زكي نجيب
محمود الفيلسوف حتى احمد بهاء الدين يعني
عايز اقول لم يكن بس دكتور فؤاد زكريا لكن
لا ده كان داخل مصر كان في كتاب كبار
وقامات كبيره
داخله عليه ابرز ما اخذ هؤلاء المفكرين
انتقدهم لافكاره انها بالنسبه لهم افكار
راجعيه
بتودينا خطوات للخلف الضر بدل ما تقدمنا
للامام طبعا لو لم يكن الشيخ الشعراوي
يتمتع بكل تلك الكاريزما وكل هذه
الجماهريه ما كانش رد الفعل بقى بالقوه دي
بس هو لانه الشعراوي يجب ان نعترف لانه
الشعراوي فكان لما بيقول حاجه في
التلفزيون في ظل كمان لازم نقول لازم نقول
للناس انه في التلفزيون الارضي كانت
الرساله اللي بتطلع من الدوله
قويه جدا لان كل البلد يعني بتتفرج عليها
يعني برزت انا لم انسى محور الفن وعلاقته
بالفن لكن حتى نشبع هذه النقطه برزت
نجوميه الشعراوي على مستوى الشعب داخل مصر
وخارج مصر في السبعينات اعتقد واستفحلت في
الثمانينات لماذا في السبعينات برزت
نجوميه
بعد رحيل جمال عبد الناصر سنه نهايه سنه
70 راحل لعبد الناصر وبدا وبدا السادات
اسات قرر ان هو يضرب الشيوعيين او
الافنديات ساعات افنديات كويس فقال لك
ضربهم بايه بطيار اخر التيار الديني وانه
هوى مصر شويه ممكن يروح نحو هذا التيار
[موسيقى]
طلعهم
كان بيدخل بعضهم السجون كان كان في يعني
ايه نوع من التعتيم على رسائلهم وكانت ما
يقولوك يسخر احيانا منهم وله وله يعني بعض
خطب بيقولها فيها سخريه
منهم فالمهم
الثلاث لما اخرجهم فبدات كمان بقى في دعم
برساله او باخرى من شيخ زي الشعراوي يعني
ثمت دعم سياسي في الموضوع انا بشوف ان
وراه طبعا لان التلفزيون الدوله مش ممكن
الدوله كانت هتسيبه يقدم اي رساله لو لم
تكن هي راضيه او مش بس راضيه تريد هذه
الرساله خاصه انه ممكن يدعم قولك هذا
الاستاذ طارق انه الشعراوي كما هو قال في
حوارات منها حوارهم مع سعيد ابو العينين
في حوار مع الهلال وغيرها انه هو كان
اخواني وهو كان صديق لحسن البنا بل انه
قال اني انا كتبت اول بيان للاخوان
المسلمين بموافقه حسن البنا ثم غادرهم
مبكرا يعني بسبب خلافات سياسيه يعني قصدي
الرجل يعرف هذا بس
نعزله يعني عن انه كان في في المجتمع
المصري كان فيه توجه عند البعض حتى جمال
عبد الناصر وخالد محي الدين قالوا ان هم
راحوا للاخوان يعني ولكن ما قالوش ان احنا
كنا اخوانيين لكن راحوا
دي كانت ليست تهمه بقدر ما انه كان تيار
موجود
لكن مؤكد انه الافكار افكار الشعراوي فيها
واخده من هذا الملح حتى فكره علاقته بالفن
خدها من حسن البنا من حسن البنا كان يقول
ايه حلاله حلال وحرامه حرام حسن البنا
استثمر في الفن
انور وجدي قبل انور وجدي بالصدفه حكى
الواقعه يعني
حقبه يعني الابيض والاسود ايوه في ست سنه
سته واربعين قبله فهو يعني قال قابلته
وقال له ازيك يا اكسلانس كلمه في الثقافه
المصريه انت عارف بتستخدم يعني ما تعنيش
اي حاجه غير انك انت بتعلن من شان المخاطب
اه لكن هو ما كانش يعني مش قادر هيقول له
مولانا
يعني ما بصليش
بانتظام انت فاكرين ان احنا مثلا احنا على
طول ان احنا بنعمل موبيقات احنا كويسين
قال له لا بالعكس اعمل فن كويس
حاله له حلال وحرام وحلال حرام وعمل مسرح
كمان مين عنده كان عنده مسرح الاخوان
المسلمين
من الفنانين راحت عندهم اشتغلت وكانت
المراه بتطلع كمان في مسرح في المسرح
الاخوان يعني عايز اقول كان عندهم
توجه بالفن يملكه البلد وانا متذكر في
السنه اللي حكمنا فيها الاخوان
الحكم مصر يعني
ايام مرسي 2012 لما بداوا انا كنت بروح
الاوبرا المصريه فكنت بقابل بعض شخصيه
الاخوانيه فهم كان في ذهنهم يعني انت اول
حاجه تفكر فيها ايه الاخوان ضد الاوبرا
الاوبرا بقى بيلبسه ومحزق وبتاع فقال لي
لا احنا هنعمل اوبرا شرعيه يعني يعني
نستكشف الابره هذه حتى الاوبرا عايزين
ياخدوها فهمت ان هم بس باسلوبهم اللي هو
يقتل الاوبرا يعني اذا عملتها شرعيه من
وجهه نظره مش هيبقى في اوبرا الحقيقه كانت
تركيبه هو اخذ من دي بقى حلال
في ليلى بنت الفقراء عمل غنوه في المولد
مول السيده زينب انت عارف في مصر وادي دي
يعني من الثقافه
فغنت ليلى مراد وكانت مسيحيه اسف كانت
يهوديه كانت لسه لم تسلم غنت لبنت بنت
النبي السيده زينب في غنوه يعني
طيب احنا احنا سنتوقف عند هذه النقطه ثم
نعود الى الشعراوي وعلاقته بالفن هذا ملف
كبير وقبلها يمكن نستعرض بعض الفتاوى اللي
كانت مثيره للجدل فاصل وجيزه لا تذهبوا
بعيدا حديثنا كان وما يزال وسيظل عن الشيخ
الشعراوي
والجدل الذي يثيره
[موسيقى]
مرحبا بكم من جديد برنامجكم الندوه
صالونها اليوم الشيخ محمد متولي الشعراوي
رحمه الله عليه ما له وما عليه شخصيه
مثيره للجدل كانت وما زالت حيا وميته مالي
الدنيا وشاغل الناس وشريكنا في نقاش اليوم
ولا اعتقد النساجد افضل منه الناقد المصري
المثقف طارق الشناوي
حديثنا كان قبل الفاصل عن الشيخ الشعراوي
موقفه من الفن لكن قلنا اثرنا ان نؤجل هذه
النقطه ونستعرض بعض ابرز الماخذ التي اخذت
على الشيخ الشعراوي من قبل معارضيه يعني
ابرز الفتاوى ابرز مثلا المواقف السياسيه
او الاجتماعيه تمثلت قبل قبل تسجيل
البرنامج بموضوع موقفه من تشغيل الاموال
فلوس المصريين الثمانينيات تعرف المصري
بيروح الخليج السعوديه الكويت
الامارات يعني
ترجع ودول هم اللي عملوا الطبخه المتوسطه
مش هيشتغل بقى ما عندوش مخ تجاري في البنك
كان بدات شركات توظيف الاموال تطلع اللي
هي لها غطاء اسلامي كويس وكانت بتديك
عشرين في الميه وساعات 25 طبعا البنك دي
15 عشر حاجات كده فبدا هو يعمل غطاء شرعي
يقول انه الفلوس البنوك ربا
ويزكي هؤلاء ما هو خلاص انا عايز اعيش
ومعايا مثلا جاي معي فلوس من السعوديه
وعايز اكمل حياتي يبقى احطهم في بنك يجيب
لي فلوس لو قلت لي ربع وبعدين كمان اقل
خدي بالك ان انه البنوك بتدي اقل من
الشركات توظيف الاموال فكل مجرد غطاء شرعي
من شيخ زي الشعراوي
هيخليك كمصري تجري تحط فلوسك ده يعني بكل
المقاييس ما فيش فيها هزار انا عايز ابقى
اقول افرق بين حاجتين عشان الناس ساعات لا
تفرق في فرق بين الشيخ الامام الشعراوي
لما يفسر القران
بثقافته
كمان في اللغه العربيه
وعنده سحر وفهم وعمق حاجه دي ما ليش دعوه
بها لان انا لا استطيع ان اجادل قام وقيمه
زي الشعراوي
لكن انا هنا لا اتحدث عن تفسير القران
انا اتحدث هنا عن اجتهاده في قضايا قد
تصيب وقد تخطئ ولزي انا لما انا هقول فيها
ممكن ابقى انا خطا وهو يبقى صح بس فزي
حكايه الربا اعتبارها ربا ده ده بالنسبه
لي لا انا شايف ان هو مش منطق لما مثلا
حكايه الاعضاء نقل الاعضاء اعتبار انها
حرام لانك انت يعني وجهه نظره انك انت لا
تملك اعضائك بتاعه ربنا او بعد الموت خلاص
ازاي تقول انا هتبرع تتبرع فيما لا تملكه
طبعا ده ضد العلم وضد الحياه وهكذا بهذا
الامر واعتقد تحدث عن الموضوع غسيل الكلى
كمان وانه الكلى طب انت ليه بتاجل بتاجل
لقائك بربنا ما تغسلش يعني شو ممكن انت
يبقى لك انسان عزيز عليك بتحبه ابنك ابوك
امك تعمل غسيل كلوي وتقول مش هعملها عشان
تلحق تقابل ربنا يعني في حاجات كتير كانت
بتصدمنا طب ما نقل الدم ليه طب ما هو
النقل الدم عضو مش كده طب ليه ليه بحلق
نقل الدم متعرضش ليه طب ما نفس الحكايه لو
فتحنا المساله لما تمنع النقل الدم كمان
بتاخد مني انا لا املكه طيب هذا يقودنا
الامر انه مثل ما تفضلت حضرتك هذا رجل ندع
موضوع علمه هذا لا جدال في خاصه في موضوع
التفسير والبلاغه لكن في مواضيع الاراء
الاخرى يؤخذ منه ويرد
ولا مقدس مهما بلغ من العلم وهذه ظاهره
مشكله بصراحه
خط احمر يعني يعني فلان خط عبد الناصر
خط احمر كلهم بنحبهم ولهم انجازهم لكن
عليهم على مستوى المشايخ طارق يعني مثلا
كان عندنا في اي اكثر من بلد يعني دعاه
معينه او معينه يقول لك لا ما تحكي عنه
هذا خط احمر وانتم ليش ما احكي عنه طيب
الامام مالك بيقول الامام مالك بن انس كان
واقف في المسجد النبوي وامام قبر الرسول
عليه السلام وقال كله يؤخذ من قبل قوله
ويرد الا صاحب هذا القبر يعني لانه مبلغ
وحي عن الله يعني لكن اجتهاده في الدنيا
لا لا طبعا لما رجال الناس وقال لهم لا
تعبرون نخل فما عبروا النخل يعني ما لقحوا
فلم ينتج النخل في السنه القادمه ما باله
نقل لكم يعني لم ينتج او اخرج قالوا انت
امرت نبيا لا نؤبره قال انما يعني انتم
ادرى بشؤ انا ما تحدثت هنا بصفه مبلغه
انسان قل انما انا بشر مثلكم يعني فلماذا
بعض الاتباع يحصنون بعض المشايخ ويضعون
عليهم هاله لا تستطيع القرب منها يعني طيب
هو افتى في الاعضاء طيب في مشايخ ثانيا
بيقولوا الاعضاء التبرع بالاعضاء او نقل
الاعضاء حلال طيب ليش هو ما حد يتكلم عنه
يعني ليش الحصانه هذه ما هو احنا عندنا
تقديس لبعض شخصيات يعني بنخليها تعلو درجه
عن البشريه عن البشر وده موجود مش بس في
الدعاه الدينيه وايضا في بعض الزعماء كل
ده خطا يعني يعني لازم ان احنا نكسر الحته
دي ويعاملوا كبشر عشان من اجل من اجل
انتعاش الحياه لكن انت لو قدستك خطوط
حمراء ممنوع ممنوع انت بتقتل العقل لا
يعني كده اذا انت لم تنتقد ما قبلك او او
تعمل عقلك في اي مقوله فانت هتبقى تتحول
الى ناقل والدنيا هتموت الحياه بتتجدد
بالتفكير
انت عندما تقرا ما يقول الشعراوي مش
بالضروره عليك انك انت تنتقده وممكن
توافقه ممكن بس عندما ياتي عقلك ولك
الراجل ده قال والله المعلومه دي صحيحه
ومزبوطه ولا اخضع للسحر
ودمه خفيف
ايقاع الموسيقي في الاداء والحركه في
اللغه الجسديه عنده ودي مهمه في مذيعه عند
لغه جسديه تحبه في مطرب يعني المطرب مش بس
صوت والداعيه برده مش بس صوت
العلاقه الجسديه او لغه الجسد عند الشيخ
الشعراوي عاليه جدا
من المشاهد لما كان قاعد في القريه بتاعته
حاول يحاكي
دي كلها الف مبارك موجوده على على قيد
الحياه يعني طيب على ذكر عادل امام والفن
يعني
كيف تصف انت عايشت هذه الرحله
صف لي بدايه الشيخ الشعراوي مع عالم الفن
وبماذا اثر في عالم الفن اثر شكل سلبي جدا
بالمقوله اللي اخذها من حسن البنا
حلال وحلال وحرام وحرام اللي ساعات كتير
ناس لما تقول لما لغايه دلوقتي حتى انا
مره شفت اشرف زكي لقيب الممثلين المصريين
قال ازاي يقول الفن حرام ده انا قعدت مع
الشيخ الشعراوي وقال حلال وحلال وحرام
وحرام يا جماعه لو قلت كده المرجعيه بقت
ايه بقت الدين مش كده كلمه حلال وحرام هي
في الترمومتر بتاعك ايه الدين الفن ليس له
علاقه كمقيال بمقياس الدين زي ما تقول لي
انه الزلزال بالقيس الزلزال بايه ريختر هل
بالقيسه بدرجه الحراره بالترومومتر بتاعنا
العادي لا كل حاجه لها مقياس الفن طب
مقياسه ايه الجمال والقبح علم الاستاتيكا
هل الفن ضد ضد الاخلاق لا
الجمال نقيسه بعلم الفن نقيسه بعلم الجمال
علم لصديقه علم الجمال وبالتالي وبالتالي
لما تقول لي حلاله حلال وحرام وحرام فانت
قصته المرجعيه عندك بقت اخلاقيه ودينيه
السؤال التاني هل الفن ضد الدين والاخلاق
اقول لك لا برده ما فيش فن بيتعمل عشان
يضرب اخلاق او يضرب ثقافه او يضرب قيمه بس
الفن له معايير اخرى لما بدا يربي عند
الناس مثلا يقابله حسن يوسف كويس حسن كان
من المغرمين به
فقال له انت حسن غلط
يا مولانا انا بتجوز في الافلام اتجوز
كتير حسن مشاهد تمثيليه يعني كتير قال له
لا حرام لا في حديث ما معناها جده
قالوا بص بقى من هنا ورايحه انت عرفت ان
ده حرام ما تعملهاش تاني طيب غير كده قال
له حاجه تانيه قال له انت علمت الناس في
شبابك قال له انا بطل تمثيل قال له لا قال
له علمت الناس في شبابك اللهو والضحك
واللعب مع البنات علمهم بقى الالتزام فطلع
من عنده يقول انا مش معتزل انا ملتزم
مش ممكن ده يبقى فكر فانا بختلف معاه في
الافكار دي ما ليش علاقه به كداعيه فعشان
كده الامور اتلخبطت عند الناس كثير قوي
وحد بيترفع عليها دعوه الزراعه اديان وحتى
احد ابناؤه قال لك هو انت تعرف ربنا عشان
يعني حتى بيتهمك في علاقتك بربنا احد
الشعراوي كتب كده عليا يعني عايز اقول كان
في مبالغات ردود فعل مبالغه جدا في انه اي
كلام متعلق بافكار وليس تفسير للقران
بافكاره او اجتهادته او ليسوا حته باحترام
رجل مقدر ومحترم ولو مكانته اكيد بس احنا
نناقشه ليس معصومة ليس مقدسا ولا معصوما
يعني كان فيه اصلا يؤثر على الجماهير يعني
مش شخصيه تقول منعزل في مكتبه او منزله
يعني كان اسمه حتى الان يعني عايز اقول لك
في وجدان الشعوب اسمه
اعلى من كثير من المطربين والممثلين يعني
دي حقيقه وهل هو انتهج نهجا سلكه من بعده
اخرون يعني قصدي ولد
الاستثمار في الفن او التاثير في الفن من
زاويه كمان اخوانيه او غير اخوانيه كان في
مجموعه فعلا كان لها اراء كتير بيطلعوا
منه بيتحجبه او يبطلوا او يقول لك نعمل فن
ملتزم وهكذا يعني كان في حاجات كتيره اثرت
على الفن والرساله بقت يعني الرساله اللي
هي بتحرم الفن صوتها اعلى من الرساله اللي
بتبيح الفني عشان كده في مصر ظهرت حاجات
زي السينما النظيفه دي دي
الفنانه تقول انا اللي اتثلاثه انا ما
لبست كذا ما عملش المشاهد
له مرجعيه اللي هي تقوم على علم الجمال صح
يعني هو هذا هذا مراد الفن وعلى هذا يقاس
وكذلك غيرهم من الفنون وفي نهايه اللقاء
انا اشكرك استاذ طارق شكرا جزيلا على هذا
اللقاء واشكركم ايها الكرام على هذه
المتابعه التي حاولنا ان نسلط الضوء فيها
على مسيره
اراء الشيخ الشعراوي بعد الجدل الذي اثير
لم نخترع هذا الجدل اثير في مصر بعدما قيل
انه ستعمل عنه مسرحيه ما له وما عليه من
حقنا ان نقول ذلك ما دام انه كان يؤثر
رحمه الله عليه على الملايين وليس مقدسا
ولا معصوما في النهايه شانه بقيه البشر
الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]